well here in germany three people have
been severely injured in a knife attack
on a high-speed train in southern
germany police say they arrested one man
believed to be the sole perpetrator the
intercity express was traveling between
the bavarian cities of regensburg and
nuremberg
there's little information about the
identity of the attacker or possible
motives at this stage a police spokesman
summed up what they do know about the
crime so far
economy
i can confirm at this hour that we have
three people who are seriously injured
but as far as i know their injuries are
not life-threatening
a 27-year-old man has been arrested in
connection with the attack
and is currently in custody
our initial suspicion is attempted
murder
that's what the current investigations
are focusing on as
i'm well by dw political correspondent
emmanuel shaz emma hi what more do we
know about the attack well what we know
so far is that the attack happened at
around 9 00 am this morning bell in a
time that's when a local police got
phone calls from the train a train where
you had around a 200 up to
two to three hundred
guests and a knife attack happened there
the german red cross confirms that three
people have been injured two
have been severely injured but do not
sustain life-threatening
injuries we also
know from a mass circulation paper bill
that police units were actually not too
far from that train because they were
due to attend
to ensure the security around the
football game in the region so they
could intervene
quite quickly to stop the train and to
arrest the
suspect we got some information from
security sources quoted by a german
press agency dpa
saying that the
suspect is a 27 year old man
and
the train is still
is still immobilized at the moment many
trains have been diverted we do not know
yet
more about the the reason for this
attack we don't know the reason for this
attack we're only just in in the in the
hours since the attack itself emma is
there anything else we know about the
suspect in terms of where he is or what
police are planning to do with him uh no
the newspaper bill the tabloid bill
actually reported that the manchester 27
year old man called for help shortly
before the attack and apparently
afterwards he attacked some of the
passengers we still uh we we have the
red cross talking about three people
injured the police hasn't uh confirmed
if we had more people injured it's still
very much
an investigation in progress we had a
reaction from joseof who's the interior
the acting interior
minister who said that this cruel knife
attack was terrible and he also thanked
all the um the trained personnel as well
as police forces for having acted
swiftly amherst thanks for the update